I think when I had about six half a
million I had a call with KSI and he was
like so wonderful to me you know and
being like one of the most intimidating
guys in YouTube and someone I've always
really really looked up to
um Mr Beast Casey neistat would like all
have been really helpful and wonderful
and I've had calls with most of them for
advice
[Music]
can you give us a little introduction to
yourself call me in it Tom Simons I'm an
18 year old sort of Minecraft streamer
and in real life content creator you've
been in the spotlight now for a few few
years yeah like before the before the
YouTube theme before the twitch fam what
were you like as a teenager
um so I think my teenage years from like
13 to 15. I like was pretty standard I
was at school I was discovering YouTube
and I was like like this is what I want
to do this is so exciting I discovered
loads of YouTubers and each one was sort
of more acquired to my taste so I
started watching these really sort of
fun Minecraft Let's Plays by Sunday and
then things got a bit more serious and
like subtler for like more subtly funny
uh by peanut butter gamer I think just
as I found it and if I will any and um
like Tom scars daily Vlogs like all of
this sort of added to my repertoire and
taste of like what YouTube could be the
YouTube twitch like the whole Community
felt like this extra like school system
on the internet and I didn't really
enjoy
school that much so having this extra
place where I really felt like I
belonged and could like level up the
rankings and really enjoy it
um I think I poured most of my passion
into that when I was sort of early
teenager why didn't you enjoy School
I think it was the environment uh and I
really loved the routine of it I loved
going in and seeing people I liked like
didn't like and that's something I still
miss now
um but I think I had like a few friends
but I think it was just that like
it almost drives you to not be yourself
at school you know you want to belong so
much that you end up doing things to
impress the people that are cooler than
you
um and I didn't like that very much I
found that like it didn't really align
with who I wanted to be
so I did YouTube for a few years like
creating it and it was really fun
um but as my school found my channel and
what I was saying about wanting to fit
in like ah like I stopped uh because I
was scared of getting made fun of
um so I think I told a girl about it to
try and impress her like I was like yeah
into Channel nut Pig uh 200 subscribers
by the way
oh you don't want to go out okay no
that's fine um and I think she like told
her mate who then told everyone
um and I think it I had this moment
where someone was just there were like
three people were just saying you're a
channel not Pig what you oh yeah Channel
not Pig and I was sat thinking
I don't like this I don't like being
Shadow like the attention in the class
where I don't have any friends I didn't
like have a like a support Circle in
that moment and I remember leaving that
thinking
that sucked I I didn't like that one bit
um and that wasn't worth it because as
much as I loved YouTube and like making
things uh it was more important to me at
the time to fit in because it was just
discovering what it was like to be a
teenager and like want to fit in getting
a bit older this must have been like
year eight I think it was just because
of school because I was never really
popular like I didn't like how I looked
or how I sort of was for a long time and
that was natural I just thought you're
either born good looking or bad looking
and I just wasn't like happy with that
um but I think as time went on and I
gained more perspective like obviously I
went it doesn't matter but while you're
in school and all you want to do is fit
in I found that
like challenging well I mean and then a
few years later I did twitch because I
knew that twitch wasn't YouTube
um
yeah and I refused to stream with like
webcam and I was super super anxious to
like have my camera in a stream I think
even until like 100 like 200 000
subscribers I was still really anxious
about showing my face
um I I had a long time where I like wish
I was faceless it's fair to say it's
gone pretty well
[Laughter]
I've got them a statue in March 2020
when we went into lockdown you were 16.
you did 130k Subs on YouTube yeah a year
later you had 6.75 million Subs
and I were another year a bit later
we've got equal 11.6 million Subs yeah
that growth is absolutely insane thank
you Hi how how did that happen
um
I think a lot of it was look if I'm
honest with you it was sort of um it's
sort of unfortunate as it sounds the
sort of pandemic coming together and
because my goal originally was by the
time I want to go to college I want to
be happy enough with my YouTube and like
be really like have it figured out in my
head but also be able to focus on life
because at secondary school I'd like I
wouldn't speak to anyone in Europe and
when everyone was going to parties and
discovering themselves and trying
alcohol I was like no I was sat in my
room by myself playing Minecraft like
making high pixel videos which I loved
right but I thought man I don't want to
sort of fall behind I still want to
experience life
um so for me it was right by the time
College happens I want to have figured
out YouTube
um and as sort of covid hit I remember
sort of everyone telling me Oh my God we
have like a six month vacation we don't
have to do anything now we can spend
like so long relaxing and I thought hmm
everyone else is going to be relaxing
now they're all going to be watching
YouTube maybe now I spend this time
doing the most like I'm working as hard
as I can while everyone else is because
then that will give me the lag
sorry daily uploaded for months on end
and I was like come on I'm trying to
find any different way
um I think because I've always been
quite outgoing and I've always just
not so much in real life in real life
I'm quite nervous and anxious but on the
internet I feel like
fine it's just like like if someone
doesn't reply to me that's not the end
of the world so I just always message
everyone hi can you call hi can can you
give me advice hi what should I do and
just that ended up meeting loads of
really cool people like dream and Wilbur
and turbo and just so many people that
like helped me along the way once you
get to about four to five thousand
subscribers you explode you hit 30 000
and then you stop and then happen with
about three four five YouTubers that
happened just before me but when I sort
of exploded and kept going like it
didn't stop and I think that was when I
went oh oh I don't know what I'm doing
this is cool like the pattern isn't it
isn't like like this is a mystery and I
can solve it because like it went you
know it went wrong I kept going and it
only slowed down from I think a few like
when I was start gaining like 7 000
around 90 000 and that was sort of oh
[ __ ] this is this is much different to
what I thought it was there's a lot more
to this and I think that sort of little
switch that was like
this is cool as [ __ ] why do you keep
exploding do you think
um well I I think my two things was I
was doing Skyblock which was a massive
Trend in Minecraft at the time and as
Minecraft was starting to come back it
was like it was quite a demand for it
and I think I sort of injected a lot
more of my personality into my video so
I learned a lesson around 3 000
subscribers I got I got banned on my
favorite Minecraft server because I was
making too many like cheating jokes and
I know I shouldn't have been I just want
to do anything like to get views because
I was like man like I want to
um and in that month I was banned I was
like man this sucks because it was just
I've been going for so long now trying
anything My Views were going down and I
had about four thousand three thousand
subscribers I was like dude this sucks
and I think during those few weeks I
went right you know I need to take this
seriously I really want to try it and I
made this one video called the fastest
clicking method
ah
I did that and then that video was the
best performing video I've ever posted
it got like I think it got like a
thousand views in two two three days and
that for me sort of triggered oh my God
the more effort you put into something
being good like what I want it to be the
more views it will get so as Hypixel
blew up I made an effort to still enjoy
Skyblock in this new game and like
accept YouTube but still make it about
me still make it about what I wanted to
do and that was quite that I mean that
was a huge eye-opening experience to
have just before sort of my popularity
you've got quite a unique experience and
that you became incredibly famous while
the world was all locked away was that
very strange then to come out of
lockdown and suddenly be recognized me I
went into lockdown you know I'd never
had anyone come up to me I was you know
like no one would ever look at me I
didn't like have the feeling of being
watched while I was in public it was so
weird because I was starting to get
recognized I didn't know that this was
and so so were all my friends like I
wasn't in this boat alone and I think
that was what going into college and
that progressing each week I went
because I had one day of college a week
that lasted for like six seven hours and
like each week getting recognized more
and more and more and people in my
college know how I was and looking at me
yeah it was weird I was quite scared of
people for a while I almost dropped out
of college really early on because I
just couldn't really handle it I was
like this is just you know I'm so happy
with all the things that have happened
but this byproduct is not something I
signed up for and so getting around my
head getting my head around that and
like deciding if I can handle it or not
was a really tasking process I sort of
went through
you said you grew up watching people
like will any and Vic star and people
and and guys like that it's weird now to
be having watched these people meeting
them in real life doing videos with them
doing the same things that's very
strange feeling yeah yeah it's a
relationship and it never really goes
away and every so often every few weeks
I'll have another moment where I'm like
just just a brief moment of reflection
where I'm like holy [ __ ] like I'm
friends with Chase oh my god
um and like yeah it is super super
strange but I think if there's one thing
I've learned about YouTube over the
years it's that everyone who makes
things is like just a person like no
one's you know no matter how much money
you have or how much popular like it
doesn't really matter because we all
have the same amount of time in the day
and we all have to like sleep and we'll
like need to
so it's like as much as it's been like
wow like this is incredible you will I
think the biggest thing I've learned is
like yeah we're all just people talking
into a camera have you spoken to any of
those guys that blew up when they were
your age like
if they giving you any advice as to
what to look out for yeah
um
yeah I mean they've all been really
really supportive honestly I I think
when I had about six half a million I
had a call with KSI and he was like so
wonderful to me you know and being like
one of the most intimidating guys in
YouTube and someone I've always really
really looked up to
um like him being like yeah dude like it
is really overwhelming and him telling
me his experiences with it but being
like you're gonna be okay and you're
doing really good and keep doing what
you're doing and like he was super
supportive
um where Lenny was wonderful I met him
in London and he was just sort of really
really nice
trying to think of other people I mean
basically everyone I've looked up to Mr
Beast Casey neistat would like all have
been really helpful and wonderful and
I've had calls with most of them for
advice but just sort of the comfort of
knowing that this is something they've
gone through and like I'm not alone in
this and yes this is stupid and this is
weird and we all are in the same boat
that we think what's happening is absurd
was really really yeah it was very
comforting
is there is there a single moment you
can think about in the last few years
you've gone I can't believe I'm here
basically most days
um
yes I think me like me and will have
been making this book at the minute
um and I'd like get up and like every
day I'd go around to his house and we'd
just like sit and work on it and when we
finished it and we like read through it
and showed I make sure bullet she was
like this is really cool being able to
like hold it was like oh my God like
this is
we've made this now and it's gonna like
be in a water stone so we walk past it
and you know I go and watch them so much
on my mum and like being like this is
like this is stupid like the first words
of it say among us there I said it
welcome to my book idiot so I was like
what like you could just do I I think
discovering that there's no rules and
that you can just do what you think is
funny like I think they're like really
realizing oh my God there's no there's
not like a rule book you have to do you
don't like have to say anything you
don't have to take sponsorships you
don't have to be corporately you just
say what you want like I can just post
me going like that on Instagram like
this second and it's there because I
always assume there must have been some
sort of rule book and as I've gotten
bigger and realized there isn't and as
I've gotten bigger more opportunities
have came and I can go right I don't
want to do my book but I want it to be
stupid and it's just like such a passion
project as well for me and will like all
the income we've made from it um like
it's dedicated to our mate tatna blades
obviously before all the stuff happened
yeah and all the income me will receive
from the book is going to be donated to
sarcoma UK but so it's just a passion
project because we thought it would be
fun and I think like
that happening and being an actual thing
has been pretty
magical as well
you talked before about not having the
kind of support network of friends
around you obviously now you've come up
with this group of guys who are all
creating content together as it'd be
nice to have people like taboo and
Wilbur and all around you oh it's been
amazing man I wouldn't have wished to do
it with anyone else like
this experience can be lonely like I've
spent so many times just sat by myself
in my room a bit teary like freaked out
and overwhelmed but
especially recently as well like being
able to go through that with people and
um with turbo and Wilbur and Jack and
like like Nick and just like everyone
and even recently you know and me and
Rambo have been in quite a similar boat
without problems because we're both
quite overwhelmed and we both have sort
of a lot of arm and it's been quite
freaky but me and him would chat for
like hours every night at twitch come
until like four or five a.m because we
both sort of have the same problems but
we've both came up with our own
individual Solutions and being able to
sort of mix and match that and
complement each other and like keep each
other going especially with Rambo
recently has been in like the past few
weeks it's been really really like I
could be more thankful I don't think I
wanted to do this with anyone else in
the world and like yeah I'm just really
lucky that I haven't been by myself as
well you seem like a really happy funny
guy but that's what they're saying
but has does the fear my heart as the
film ever had any negative impacts on
your mental health
um
yes
um I mean I think the the biggest thing
because sort of so much of my like image
on the internet has been about my face
especially when I was having that huge
sort of explosion on YouTube Every
thumbnail and it still has been for the
past two years has had my face in this
very top in it um I think that has been
weird because I'm just sort of
the feeling of being watched in public
like you have this Indescribable feeling
when someone's staring at you like right
now I'm looking at you and you can just
like feel it but when I'm looking at you
away
like you just know right you just really
get when someone's staring at you and
having to get just like used to the
feeling of just always having that okay
and even if you're not looking you can
like feel it behind you you know and
will buyers goes like that at the end of
strange things you really like have that
I think getting used to that and getting
used to getting recognized and having to
view it in an optimistic light and not
being like
bye-bye privacy um has been it was it
was a real Challenge and there were many
months of being you know like sad
because I get quite overwhelmed easily
um because but you can have a million
positive things happening and trying to
appreciate and like take in having one
huge overwhelming thing that's in my
face I've found really difficult for uh
the early 2021 but being able to stream
and do YouTube and like being able to
make something got me through that and
like seeing the amount of people that
are actually there and care about the
things that I'm making and like to
support me and like the creators and
like everyone
it totally got me through it I can ask
do you feel like like because you blew
up so quickly do you feel a pressure to
maintain that growth I think for a long
time idea to really feel that pressure
especially in sort of late last year
early this year I think loads of us did
because the way YouTube works is it like
Ebbs and flows you know you look at any
one social blade they have the biggest
month and their lowest month and a
middle month and a high month and a low
month but for us it was all up then all
down and that was you know like the
psychology of that really like affected
me and I had quite a long time of being
numbers driven and being up like about
the byproduct and not the original thing
I was making
but as I've gone to more conventions and
as I said like connected with people
I've realized what I'd much rather like
have is I whether it's a few thousand or
currently it's like two to five million
people that will watch my video like I'd
rather have two million people that
really connect with what I do and really
enjoy it and really want to talk about
it and want to know what I'm gonna do
next then like 100 million people that
see it and go okay
and then watch the next thing you know
it's more important to me I think to
have that like actual connection with
people and success can be like many
different things like how a few thousand
people feel about my video you know like
the reception of that in comments or in
like just how it's talked about in the
future and years to come I think there's
so many elements of success than just
this rampant uh sort of view flurry and
I find that element of YouTube fun I
find that strategy really fun but I'm
not like good at predicting it so I
really enjoy expanding on something when
I've made something I'm proud of and it
sort of aligns with what I want to do
next but I think like
in a way I wouldn't have answered this
last year like no I'm not obsessed with
getting 20 million subscribers I'm just
obsessed with those few million people
whether that's 2 million or 5 million or
10 million like it was last year and
maybe in the future it'll be 5 000
keeping those people like yeah making
those people proud and making them think
God it's been two years I've been
watching him and he's still putting an
effort and he's still spicing things up
and doing new things and going back to
the old things with the new stuff so
continuing that effort you know never
stopping that effort because I think
it's really important yeah and aligning
that with what I'm doing so in the
future if I need to upload less or more
that's like cool but never how far I'm
never doing a half job with a full smile
you're in now the kind of next
generation of YouTubers and you've seen
people like Logan Paul and KSI who've
become these big big names where where
do you think you're going to be in 10
years where do you want to be
um
the whole thing is sort of like
specifically doing what I enjoy and like
putting that out there so for me like my
friend Rambo is always streaming
different horror games in a different
game every night I still stream
Minecraft most evenings because the game
I love so much is Minecraft
um I think just like
oh as time goes on trying like I never
thought I'd make a book or do a show but
like making an effort to try new things
and then go do a right Club did I not
like that like do I like music do I like
doing bigger projects do I like you know
and and for me going holy [ __ ] I I do
like being on a stage this is cool holy
[ __ ] I do like going to conventions I
didn't even know I could do that and
then you know maybe in a few months
going oh okay music's good this is a
really good way to express myself and
just being like really open to the
opportunities of like what I want to do
next and for me the best way of doing
that has been being like right what can
I do now that I couldn't have done a
year ago
um like because now I can make a serious
video and now I have more people that
can help me so I can make like a bigger
Minecraft mod video and now I can stream
in my like apartment like what things
can I do that are like different but
what that would be like what what thing
I'd hold that I could show you is my
video from next year I have no idea but
I really like that I don't know I think
it keeps it really exciting for me and
hopefully for the audience
are you really proud of how far you've
come
yeah I'm the best
[Laughter]
no yeah I think we'll do a hard cut
there
um yeah yeah I think so I think my past
self will be pretty chuffed
um I think it takes it's taking like a
long long time to to sort of take in the
things that have happened but as I do
each new project and like
I think most of this I can't comprehend
because why should I be able to that I'm
sat in a set and I'm 18 and I'm not at
University studying editing like I
should be you know like I saw all my my
photos of all my schoolmates going to
prom they have almost a prom and I was
just like not in any of the photos and I
was like man
why aren't I there like this is where I
should be you know uh see like me and my
friend Aaron were just not because we
dropped out of college and I moved down
south and like I was like that's weird I
can't take in any of the millions or any
of the play buttons or world records and
like I don't I don't get that but I
think when I have those few moments that
twitch comes vidcons or just in the
street or with my friends or where I'm
thinking that like I really can take in
like like I get
um being able to just cherish those
moments is something that's been came
increasingly important to me
um and yeah I think I'm starting to get
it as each year goes by I feel a bit
more like I I get it a little bit but
not very much
you seem like a very nice grounded young
man yeah the subscribe
I remember when it kind of first started
off
um a group of us were just out to out to
dinner and we very Darkly
you know sort of said who's who's gonna
be next and we you know chatted and came
up with a list of about
seven people and within six months all
of them were gone